ninja hates women social media hates
Alex Jones and ksi hates PewDiePie I'm
poppy Harlow and you're watching Kunis
good evening I'm poppy Harlow a lot of
stuff to talk about today so let's just
ninja explains his choice not to stream
with female gamers maybe he just
respects them too much I find it
infuriating I know I'm not supposed to
give my opinion
I'm just poppy Harlow but you have any
other youtuber like PewDiePie that
respects women so much and he hardly
gets any credit for it and then your
hair you have ninja I don't approve of
it I find this very interesting because
there was a lot of different opinions
around this not just between anyone but
also between youtubers and streamers and
I especially find it interesting because
as always everyone is a [ __ ] but meet
poppy Harlow
first of all agreeing with an interview
to polygon who would have thought that
was a bad idea that's where this started
ninja made a very offhand remark saying
I don't play with female streamers
because I want to avoid all the gossip
that comes with that now anyone that's a
public figure understands what he means
but a lot of people also make pretty
reasonable claims against this statement
saying I understand but he could still
play with them and not care about the
rumors both act professionally and get
professional results someone else saying
who cares if a bunch of Nimrods online
think you're cheating on your wife or
something because you had a friendly
exchange with a female gamer during
stream in any other job this is true but
on the Internet
what you don't understand is the people
are insane especially when it comes to
relationship people are crazy so while
it's reasonable to criticize ninja for
doing this saying well can he just brush
it off are you gonna ignore it
for example Dodger another youtuber
streamer who commented about this saying
when Sam and I got together some of my
viewers harassed not only him
but his mother's and sisters someone
hired a private investigator to find
evidence he was cheating someone else
found porn star look-alikes and send me
videos of them it received countless of
emails about what a scumbag he was and
how he shouldn't be with me if people
have something to say about your
relationship online they will say it and
maybe Nina doesn't care maybe it's his
wife that that doesn't like it who knows
and even if they both don't care is
certainly not a fun thing to deal with
these sort of things and I've seen it
myself of other youtuber couples a
relationship becoming more complicated
because other people had things to say
about it online oh well why is he with
this person he should be with her they
are way too cuter together look at this
you know it's easy for me to say this
but I think what Nina should have said
is there's a problem with me streaming
online with all the females because all
these rumors and gossip come along with
it and I already have enough stuff to
deal with that I can't even be bothered
to put myself and my wife through that
so I avoid playing with other famous
streamers because that's what already a
lot of streamers do I know for a fact
that youtubers and streamers don't
collaborate or play with other females
because they know it will just be a
bunch of drama and yes with it and it's
just not worth it this is really the
ugly truth of the internet and the only
thing ninja is guilty of here is to
explain it and putting it out there
besides people calling in your sexist
because of this there was a lot of
people that were very entitled because
of this being having reactions such as
quoting him I would gladly use my
platform the biggest platform of all of
twitch to boost other mail streamers
like that was given to him for free or
something like that such a dumb comment
sorry girls were already had aren't
anywhere to be found in the top hundred
twitch streams I can't play with you
lest idle rumor destroys my marriage nah
he's scum he can play with whoever he
wants no one is entitled to play with
ninja no matter who you are such a
stupid remark and I saw a lot of people
comment like this
and I think also it's a lie that's the
reason why a lot of people are inset
polygon this was clearly such an offhand
remark this was a ninja making a
statement being like this is why they
even have to fill in his quote with
these brackets saying like gossip he's
talking about gossip they really just
wanted to stare drama and this is
literally old that it is then my own
personal thoughts relationships and
friendships when you're a public figure
it's almost like you live two lines I'm
not talking about my own relationship my
relationship with might say was great
shut up I know people online there are
youtubers that pretend like they're
they'll make it seem like they're
friends online but in reality they might
not like each other at all in reality
they never see each other but it's more
convenient for other people in line to
think they are friends because it's just
easier to deal with it that way they
don't want to deal with all the drama
that comes out because of it it's the
same reason why a lot of times
relationship that everyone thought saw
as this perfect example of a good
relationship they break up I don't know
where and everyone is just shocked being
like how did this happen they were
perfect couple goals it's almost like
they pretend their relationship is a
certain way to get it approved online
because this is easier that way imagine
being judged by hundreds and thousands
of people about your private personal
relationship I'm poppy Harlow now you
understand the internet and youtubers
and a little better you're welcome Alex
Jones fan we need to talk about the Alex
Jones Bay I didn't want to talk about it
because at first I didn't know much
about it and I knew it was just going to
make things more complicated with me
whether the videos demonetized or create
more media drama or alright I wasn't
wrong for having this idea because a
tree a tree got a strike while talking
about Alex Jones in a live stream their
live stream got shut down
now YouTube said this was made an error
but it happened so why am i doing it now
that's a great question
I'm interested about this whole thing
the more I read about it not necessarily
Alex Jones himself but the whole climate
around it so what happened well Facebook
Apple YouTube n Spotify banned Alex
Jones and for those of you who are not
familiar with Alex Jones I can't really
describe him either because I don't
watch his content
I only really know Alex from memes and
they're really funny videos
[Music]
now despite him being a very goofy
character I understand why he's
controversial I understand that he's
impacted people in a negative way and if
people don't like him I think they have
every reason not to this is not me
defending Alex but with Facebook Apple
YouTube in Spotify banning him
ironically I don't think this is a big
conspiracy
I think these websites dinner in
companies didn't want Alex on them for a
long time and now they got sort of a
ripple effect way to get rid of him in
an easy and quick way it started with
Apple removing his podcast and then
YouTube and Facebook joined along and
Spotify as well while for a lot of
people who might be obvious why he got
removed for people that don't know Alex
Jones and the reasoning being so vague
how do you break for different Community
Guidelines on four different website at
the same time now a lot of articles to
explain to people why Alex Jones is bad
they bring up his comments around 9/11
and Sandy Hook but her spokesperson
noted that none of these violation that
spurred today's removal were related to
this YouTube saying that all users
agreed to comply with our Terms of
Service and Community Guidelines when
they sign up to use YouTube that was it
that was all they said so Alex went to
stream on Twitter's periscope as soon as
where this happened and a lot of people
had very strange reaction in my opinion
- why isn't Twitter banning Alex Jones
as well why Twitter is tolerating Alex
Jones according to the right-wing four
theories well it's pretty clear I mean
they said it we didn't suspend Alex
Jones or Infowars yesterday we know
that's hard for many but the reason is
simple he hasn't violated our rules
we'll enforce it if he does but a lot of
people's reaction to this is while you
need to change the rules you're being
cowards you need to get rid of him we
need to get rid of Alex Jones people
saying you and your platform is a
dangerous joke this is double standards
people calling him a coward saying you
need better rules just like Twitter said
themselves unless alex preaches ideas
that goes against Twitter's
community guidelines or rules then he
shouldn't be banned from Twitter I find
it almost dumbfounding how people
disagree with this centenary this
statement I've seen the argument saying
well these are private companies Apple
Spotify YouTube and whatever they have
the right to ban whoever they want they
can set their own rules they should just
make up rules to get rid of Alex Jones
it seems pretty fair right they're their
playground their rules I also kind of
disagree I think that social media has
grown so big that it's become an
extension of your voice that if you're
not on social media and you are taken
off of social media in a way that isn't
really specified why then it can be seen
as a way of censorship so I think
Twitter did the right thing for being
careful and banning him for not having a
specific reason maybe I'm too young not
that young
maybe I'm too naive but if you don't
like someone or something you speak up
against it you don't shut them out you
don't remove them Alex to me is someone
you laugh it's something you don't take
seriously and I know that can be seen as
an angle again for some people I think
Alex Jones is a Hydra
if you cut him off someone else was just
take his place
and we have more reason to be angry
about it and created an even more
divisive political situation with the
person that says the government is
turning the frogs game is that really
when it's necessary that's my opinion
about it
finally ksi hates PewDiePie what did he
say
let's watch TDP I recently chipped him
so you heard what he said about you guys
being scumbags and accused you have both
been in just for the money what do you
think about that is that true
well I mean he has no ground to talk at
all
he is probably but now he is the person
that ruined a lot of people's lives on
YouTube with his comments and his all
and she said summative
but yeah yeah he didn't help with that
okay all right here's the thing I called
him and Logan scumbags for being purely
money driven with this whole event
thinking about it that's fine like
what's wrong with that
I think chaos is clearly motivated by
this fight he's clearly into fighting
and I find it entertaining yes it's
completely meaningless but it's fun to
follow so I can't really hate on that
and I think it was a dumb coming for me
to make I feel like this whole metro
asking like Felix said this bad thing
about you his response was just purely
like well I guess I respond with
something bad back like I didn't even
correlate to what I said there's always
been a long drama between me and ksi and
I don't even know why like it seem like
he doesn't care I don't really care
either and everyone would send me this
video like oh did you see what he said
oh my god what is your response I'm just
like I don't care I'm sure we would get
along fine like I'd have a beer with him
what do you say ksi smash like on this
video if you agree to end this drama
once and for all
can we bring peace finally and and show
an example of hope for the world what do
you say that was it for me I'm poppy
Harlow hope you guys enjoy watching pew
news I don't know why I make these this
seems like it makes my life more
complicated but if you enjoy penis and
one is report-it I very much appreciate
a great way to do that is to hit the
join button it's a great way to support
me or by the merch I design it you'll
look cool wearing it and you support me
it's a win-win situation everybody
that's it for me see you tomorrow with
another video goodbye
[Music]